Pearl Jam and Nirvana hit right gigantic
record companies went to Fugazi there's
something on my face a black speck yeah
I was like what the [ __ ] part of the mic
yeah like the phone you saw no what the
[ __ ] bro you have a direct line to my
face but I thought it was a mole - I
don't know you that well I've never been
this close for you for this long lasting
on my face you didn't say [ __ ] but it's
fine I'll let it go that's a good topic
I will kind of he's a type of person if
you had [ __ ] smeared across your face he
would never tell you and he would allow
you to walk into your room and speak to
a hundred people which [ __ ] smeared on
your face so I don't know why you're
coming after him worse because um you
know when they tell burger burgers and
things and teeth you don't tell him no
he doesn't know you could have a pie
pizza on your face I want anything I I
do I I resist and I tried to go as long
as I can without too much and then and
then I always end up telling and then I
always get in trouble for it why don't
you tell me sooner why did you tell me
kind of there we go it's like sometimes
it doesn't work but usually I'll be like
I'll do this for them yeah or are you
rubbing alright like I don't do that I
just rub their nose for them okay and
then they're like oh that's kind of
sweet and now we're closer I always have
that problem when people ask me to tell
the truth you know like especially chefs
they'll ask me like tell me how that
really was and then my wife would sit
don't tell
because and then I always do and then
they they end up climbing up and walking
away yeah stop telling people do you
know when I was when I watched this
latest season of Chef I was what I took
from it was like oh they really are
different kinds of teachers because
nothing made me more anxious than
watching Wolfgang Puck yeah look over
Jon Favreau making that omelet just wait
well Wolfgang Puck is an actual guy
there's an actual guy named wolf bang
gang bang oh you thought it was just a
restaurant
no I thought it was like Chef Boyardee
there's no guy named by Ord that's what
that's [ __ ] called
there's a guy named Wolfgang Puck
Wolfgang Puck
there's an actual why is there a PF
Changs there is a Philip Chiang there we
go okay okay there is a PF j there is a
PHA is he nice oh [ __ ] he's white he's
not American he's not Wolfgang Hindman
Arnold came together yeah oh really
he's been around forever game Park and
Arnold are brothers all the emigrated
here together in the same plane yes and
he broke that whole like Vegas buffet
thing and he started putting like nicer
high-end spa go in and his first Pago
was right by The Comedy Store yeah
that's right
I've heard a spa go that's Wolfgang Puck
yeah yeah little bit
I feel like an idiot right now I feel
foolish
you know what's okay but you know when I
was I was like okay there's a very right
in your ear
so there's bad if
sowed and then there's your episode a
best friend and I was like oh I could
never learn from someone like Wolfgang
because breathing down my neck like I
was absolutely shut down but you're more
of like here's this very clear very I'm
like a surf instructor yeah but Wolfgang
is very European that's all